I already got a cease and desist letter
last time so I might get sued for saying
this but we have to talk about the fraud
and lies that are catching up with safe
Moon and their CEO John caroni last time
we uncovered millions of dollars of
stolen company money but this time it
gets even worse I'm being threatened for
uncovering Shell companies and worse so
is John's mom so look guys we're on like
part five of this safe Moon expose so if
you haven't watched the previous videos
some of this might not make a ton of
sense we're deep in the coffees a little
lower here we're deep in the 10 million
dollar studio so I've got a couple of
options first you can go watch those
videos and then jump to this time stamp
for when we're gonna discuss the rest of
it or I can give you a super quick recap
the summary is that safe moon is a
formerly billion dollar cryptocurrency
which promised to take their investors
safely to the Moon in a move that
surprised no one uh they then defrauded
those investors by stealing unstealable
funds turns out that the money That was
supposed to be like locked up
automatically wasn't locked up
automatically and um despite this
somehow safe Moon still maintains a
pretty cult-like fan base called the
safe Moon Army by promising pretty much
everything from gambian wind farms to
nanotechnology uh and delivering on
absolutely none of it I mean to
understand the absolute horror of being
a safe Moon investor uh just picture you
know your dad right he promises you
everything one Christmas promises you
the whole Walmart catalog the little
kid-sized jeep that actually drives all
of it and then the time comes and you
get nothing and he steals your grandma's
card with a hundred dollars in it that's
what it's like being invested in safe
Moon last year X except instead of just
one dad there are several dads in the
safe Moon history which have promised
things and like been stolen the money uh
but these days there's really only one
dad worth talking about who hasn't gone
out for cigarettes yet
um okay maybe this Dad analogy's gone a
bit too far but the point is that man
well who's actually not a dad
incidentally is John caroni the CEO
current CEO John was basically broke
before safema now I don't mean that
disparagingly I mean it has a matter of
record he admits to living in a trailer
on Instagram saying that uh he was like
living a van life or something now
what's funny about this is his own
brother responded to it that it wasn't
so much van life as it was John mooching
off his parents for free utilities I
don't know what you want to call that or
we calling this uh living at home with
extra steps or van life it's up to you
either way John hit it big when he got
attached to Safe Moon he quickly became
a multi-millionaire after he stole money
which was supposed to be for investors
which we all discovered accidentally
because of a wiener dog nft that John
posted to Instagram to show up we here
at Coffee Zilla call that wiener gate
and unfortunately it's too hard to talk
about here today uh you can go watch a
video about that here but either way
this proved that John had millions of
dollars of crypto that he shouldn't
right because the whole idea was we're
locking the money away we're not going
to touch it for like four years or
something uh it turns out of course they
did but it got me thinking once we found
this I wanted to know where did this
money go where is he putting all this
crypto right he doesn't keep it all in
crypto and that's what we're gonna find
out today now one last piece of context
that I do think is important uh most of
the people who formerly worked with John
caroni told me the same thing basically
uh he's terrible to work with and quite
ruthless as you'll see in these
recordings there's like no substance of
a human there anymore
John's a [ __ ] monster and does not care
about his employees whatsoever and this
is going to sound really [ __ ] up and I
apologize in advance the only time I
like John is when he's depressed now
again I I don't mean that to show him
disparagingly I just think it's
important uh context because the safe
Moon Army still believes that John is
basically their savior he's the good guy
in their eyes and everyone else is bad
because of John that really is their
narrative but it's a narrative that
starts falling apart when you realize
the pattern of behavior with everyone
you know it's like that one friend you
have that always has problems with other
people right they're always have drama
with everyone and they blame it on
everyone but themselves and at some
point you always think like well maybe
there's a common denominator here and
that brings us all to today because
today I'm here to share even more
evidence that John crony might be
stealing from safe Moon holders some of
this is brand new evidence some of it is
old evidence that I uncovered that I've
been unable to talk about because of
lawsuit threats from John's lawyers
because a couple of months ago I just
discovered a multi-million dollar real
estate portfolio that John crony was
hiding in Shell companies which again is
pertinent because you know before safe
Moon he had no money and in safe when he
wasn't supposed to have a way to get
money so where did it come from
um so obviously you know what I think
but the point is when I went to uncover
this information John's lawyers they
sent me a season assist said hey we're
gonna sue you if you leaked this
information and the thing is I had
already done so much on them that I knew
that somehow this information would come
out like they're really bad at hiding
things so I decided look I'm just gonna
hang back I'm just gonna wait I know
this is gonna leak eventually and uh
turns out it was I was right it did just
not in the way I expected because the
leaker of the information wasn't some
disgruntled employee it was John caroni
accidentally leaking the information
public when he sued his own mother Yes
you heard that right John caroni is
suing his own mother for embezzlement if
you don't believe me here's the lawsuit
right here which I got by paying three
dollars on Pacer it's called journalism
I mean I know you guys wonder you know
if this is such a big deal why isn't it
everywhere in the presses well I don't
know maybe they don't have three dollars
I don't know I I don't think the New
York Times has a Pacer account right
um actually a serious story people did
approach me about doing this as like a
docu-series or something like that after
we put out a report but when I'd fully
explained it to him they'd be like
yeah uh can we make this a bit simpler
can we dumb it down I mean these people
their audiences they think the
blockchain is like a Tetris mobile game
you know they they're trying to erase
the blockchain from this whole story and
it's like not sure you can do that and
still you know see the fraud but this
part of the story I don't know how much
I can make it simpler right this guy is
literally suing his mom for embezzlement
while himself being accused of
embezzlement it's honestly insane it's
to say that the story isn't everywhere
right now but today we're gonna break it
all down you know how did John coroni go
from being living in a trailer at his
mom's house uh to the lambo suing his
mom for a house because that's happening
too and at the end I'm also going to be
telling you the details of why John
Croney threatened me to sue me you know
innocent me I know it's hard to believe
because honestly it's entirely possible
that me and Mrs caroni could be taking
the stand together against Josh you know
it's it's about I know it sounds funny
sounds crazy it's a possibility I could
be setting up a GoFundMe be for me and
her legal fees very soon
it could be happening so thank you for
pumping the stock thank you for
supporting the channel uh you guys all
make it all possible but without further
Ado let's get into this lawsuit
all right so this is the lawsuit between
John caroni um and his mother uh through
a company uh called ECG and look I know
many of you you got the popcorn out
you're ready for the family drama but
let's start by
talking about a few things right first
of all I need to say I'm not airing out
John caroni's family problems this is a
public court case anyone has access to
it like I said a few bucks so I cannot
stress enough that John chose to air out
all this information like he's the one
they're the ones writing the documents
with the lawyers or whatever they put it
out publicly okay first secondly and
this is also extremely important on the
one hand I do find it funny that Jon is
suing his mother for embezzlement
because you know he's also being accused
of embezzlement and his plan I guess to
fight that is like oh instead of
addressing the accusations let's just
accuse my mom of embezzlement uh you
know that's a classic That's a classic
excuse we'll see how that plays out for
him right so yes I find all of that
funny but that's not why we're doing it
because it turns out this lawsuit is
also incredibly helpful for unraveling
the entire safe Moon story there's a lot
of lies in here that start falling apart
when you see it uh because as you'll
find out
Jennifer caroni John's mom
absolutely torches him in this lawsuit I
mean it might as well be addressed to
coffeezilla the way some of this stuff
is written I think she knew like some of
it the way it was like put in the
lawsuit I think it was her way of you
know exposing him because I didn't think
she needed to put it in and then I think
it was like I brought you into this
world I'm gonna take you out so as we go
through this lawsuit though I'm gonna be
bringing this all back to how this
relates to safeman because again that's
why we're talking about it that's the
bigger picture here now the details of
how this lawsuit came about as I said
safe moon from the early days they
promised a lot right gambian wind farms
nanotechnology the list went on and on
which all started when John starts
talking about all these you know code
name projects he starts talking about
Darkmoon area 32 uh operation Phoenix
operation Phoenix is is a little bit of
a journey but it's mainly a bunch of
different complex things coming together
to create an evolution but in reality
this loss was that he wasn't pioneering
much as much as he was piggybacking off
of his parents achievements the
following is from the sign Declaration
of Jennifer caroni John's parents are
apparently extremely involved in The
Gambia and have been for some time they
quote began establishing valuable
government and business relations which
resulted in them having valuable
relationships invitations approvals and
licenses to do business in The Gambia
the point is they had connections and
John wanted to use them so he decides
okay he's now got a ton of cash
through safe Moon and he's going to
invest in the family business so him and
his mom create a company called ECG
which is like I guess part of what they
were doing there they also have other
companies too uh it's called the
emanations Communications Group which is
a terrible name whatever we're calling
it ECG the big point is this John is
joining mom and getting 33.3 percent of
profits for future sales of some antenna
technology doesn't really matter but the
point is John is getting that percentage
because he's funding it with his quote
personal wealth ladies and gentlemen it
can't be expressed how big of a point
this is is it like The Smoking Gun in
the lawsuit because this document does
not say John caroni manifested his
desire to diversify his company's wealth
of cryptocurrency it says his personal
wealth his personal piggy bank and the
reason this matters is because the
amount of personal wealth he put into
this company with five million dollars
now I want you to ask yourselves pretend
you're the jury for a second right we've
seen evidence that John was living in a
van before safeman suddenly he joined
safe moon in March of 2021 and by June
2021 he's got five million dollars to
invest of personal crypto wealth like as
the jury tell me the conclusion where
did he find that money did he find the
Bitcoin under his Vans mattress or did
he get the money from investors I really
don't care how high you are on safe boom
copium you cannot pretend that this
could have come from like even just a
salary right even if he was getting paid
as the CEO of safeman what is he getting
paid a million dollars a month look at
the Timeline March 2021 van life June
2021 5 million dollars personal wealth
it doesn't take a scientist to figure
out what's going on here it takes three
dollars in a Pacer account journalism uh
what we find out next though is even
more wild because the reason John
accuses his mother of embezzling money
is apparently because he thinks that she
spent a bunch of the money from ECG
which is their shared company she spent
it in dividends on things like cash
transfers fashion purchases guns and
hair apparently 258 thousand dollars
which is certainly a lot of money but
coroni's moms argues that this is just
her regular salary and was
mischaracterized and honestly the reason
the gun was even bought was because her
son had attracted threats she says quote
the firearms and Munitions were personal
expenditures deemed necessary in light
of me and Bradford's names being
included in threats against John which
obviously that's totally understandable
and looks terrible for John like
literally imagine leaking the fact uh
that your parents fear for their safety
because of your actions and then
accusing them of embezzlement because of
it now obviously it's pretty
understandable why their relationship
was starting to deteriorate at this
point but it got worse when Jon started
claiming all their hard work so sort of
as his own he started renaming their
companies ECG and ECG operations and
called them Dark Moon and area 32 to the
safe Moon Army to make it look like he
was doing a bunch of work his mom tried
to tell him that this was extremely
cringe but he didn't listen now the
reason this is important again is
because in context with safe Moon John
was making it sound like he's this
innovator he he's this Evolution guy
he's leading the church but in reality
he was just taking credit for other
people's work and he would allegedly
even leak proprietary information which
they asked him not to leak
um and it just led to more of a riff
between them now of course at this point
the Gambia was still a big part of safe
Moon's narrative and story so John
couldn't let this weakening relationship
last for very long so he decides to make
a last-ditch effort to go to The Gambia
and repair relationships and you'd think
at this point that Jon would sort of
humble himself and take the L but
instead it turns out that allegedly he
went behind his mom's back to the
business partners in The Gambia that the
parents had spent years building up
these relationships and tried to cut her
out of her own deal allegedly he tried
to bribe her friends and business
partners with 350 000 contingent on them
cutting her out which oh my gosh have
you no shape this woman not only birthed
you she brought you the whole deal and
luckily for Jennifer her business
partners refused but John doubles down
and says I'll give you 4.5 million
dollars if you do it and also get rid of
these pesky regulations around approving
you know my plans Etc to which her
Partners In The Gambia were like uh no
that's not how any of this works and
John's reaction was apparently quote to
improperly transport business assets and
property to include personal property
across International borders guys I will
let your imagination run why with what
these personal assets were or business
assets I mean was it a car was it a
plane was it secret documents I don't
know the accusation is that he stole
stuff though either way and honestly
John caroney just kind of comes off like
a bond super villain here he doesn't get
his way so he just steals stuff and
leaves across International borders and
bear in mind this is coming from his own
flesh and blood that is making these
accusations his own mom now they called
this whole event the March 2022
invitation in the lawsuit and
incidentally this is also when John's
own brother Charles caroni decided he
was going to leave safe moon at the time
he said it was because he wanted to go
back to college but looking back at the
Timeline it seems pretty clear and now
that the gloves are off Charles his
brother is saying publicly quote sorry
this was said before his suing my mother
face so the whole family seems to have
turned against John and at this point
even his uncle is tweeting about the
dark Triad uh he's tweeting about coffee
makers how much he loves this coffee
machine in the same month that we were
exposing John it's just all going pretty
horribly for John but again I'm not
saying this you know for the drama or
whatever I'm saying this because this
all relates to safe mode this is a
company that people have put their trust
in their money in and John's leading the
ship because let's put these pieces
together you know safe Moon started with
a bunch of Founders they all left the
company or got run out of the company by
John crony then his family gets involved
they all get run out of the company
everyone hates Jon because they seem to
be getting screwed John's ending up rich
the investors are ending up poor I mean
this isn't too complicated to figure out
unfortunately though I have to harp on
this point because each time something
like this happens some new revelation
comes out about John crony something
unbelievable each time the people in
safe Moon try to rationalize what he has
done like right now I kid you not one of
the top posts on their subreddit is
justifying why John had to sue his
mother not did Sue his mother mother why
he had to do it in this post the
conclusion is Sue is the only correct
answer
I mean at this point if you can
rationalize this your CEO trying to ruin
his mother's reputation accusing her of
embezzlement all the while facing his
own embezzlement charges you might you
might be in a cult you know it's just
it's gone too far of course though this
isn't over because with safe moon it's
never over there still is more evidence
here because after torching the deal in
Gambia uh John does what he does best
and he shifts the goal post because
instead of saying you screwed up he
releases a Captain's Log saying you know
what the Gambia ain't so hot after all
Quote while The Gambia will always hold
a high place in my heart and priorities
the recent trip illuminated Myriad other
opportunities in other parts of Africa
which is certainly one way of saying you
botched the deal now next I do want to
cover my own involvement in this whole
safe Moon Saga as I said I received a
cease and desist letter from John coroni
and I want to talk a bit about that the
gist of it is that it relates to a
certain shell company uh that John
caroni created to hide a housing
portfolio basically he's just hiding
more of his money he called it the Ronin
real estate company and I the way I
found it was through his lawyer Curtis
walthius a family lawyer now right about
the time I found out that John had been
buying houses with cash and a
multi-million dollar real estate
portfolio somehow he found out that I
knew and uh you know he sent a letter
basically saying that like we know that
you know and if you say anything about
this we're going to sue you because it
would endanger John in some way uh which
to be clear I would have never doxed
personal information or you know any
addresses or anything like that I just
thought it was highly relevant to
investors you know when they're
suffering that their CEO their fearless
leader is now living in a mansion I
think that's relevant but at the same
time I'd already revealed so much wrong
doing the safe Moon I didn't feel like
it was worth the risk at this point and
I just felt like it was best to just
kind of step back and see how this whole
thing would shake out because I kind of
had a feeling uh that this stuff would
leak because it's pretty hard to hide
the fact if you're snatching up houses
like the Monopoly man and it turns out
once again John leaked the information
himself he put his secret little Ronin
real estate company in the lawsuit
against his mom he blew his cover wide
open why because he was complaining
about the fact that he helped his
parents with like a down payment and now
sort of wants the down payment back from
his parents because they put it in the
wrong company's name
um and in a Twist of irony he actually
names the exact street where his parents
house is located and sort of almost
doxes them which is funny to me because
you know he's threatening me how dare
you I didn't even reveal anything he's
like how dare you I'm going to send you
cease and desist letters whatever
meanwhile he's suing his parents and he
puts their address in there while
knowing that his parents are having to
go out and buy guns because of you know
all his Shenanigans online how insane is
that and by the way his parents have a
whole explanation of why you know this
house that John helped buy isn't in
John's Ronin real estate name that's
what John wanted the reason is is
because of the title company and the
fact that apparently uh John's dad is
like a retired peace officer and you
know he could get the house uh houses
addressed privatized because of that
which would be great because their
address wouldn't be listed publicly
online that's what they wanted John of
course goes up and blows this up by
putting their street name in in the
lawsuit but either way it's just kind of
a mess now again how does this relate to
Safe Moon though of course well it turns
out while leaking his secret shell
company uh John's mother also revealed
the fact that John was using his
personal wealth to buy these houses
again this is a multi-million dollar
real estate portfolio so where did he
get all this money all this personal
wealth she says in a sworn statement all
this funding was understood to be John's
own personal wealth guys it's
unequivocal that means that all these
houses that John has in his name is his
personal houses so ladies and gentlemen
once again we find that John's rich
provably I mean his own mother saying it
and his investors are poor that is the
legacy of safe Moon and yet unbelievably
once again the investors still aren't
getting it and you know honestly when I
first exposed safe moon for Millions
stolen uh the the safe Moon Army told me
you know that's old fun when I expose
Ben Phillips for Millions stolen from
him they tell me oh that's the old team
when I expose Papa on a phone call they
told me oh well he's just a bad apple
when I started exposing John is when
they freaked out and they go no no he's
not he's not bad he's the good guy in
this whole thing you know I expose 100
million dollars stolen they said ha you
finally made a mistake only 6.3 million
dollars was stolen which to be fair they
were right it wasn't 100 million it was
6.3 million uh I'm just not sure that's
the win that they think it is the fact
that any money was stole is sort of the
problem and my overall point is if you
can believe that you know the old team
was corrupt if you can believe that
money has been stolen what is so
difficult what is The Logical leap
That's So Impossible about maybe the
current CEO is bad too you know I just
don't really understand it uh because
people are fighting for this guy like
they're John's mom meanwhile John's own
mom is getting sued and she doesn't even
like him you know like I don't get it
I've never seen anything like this you
know I'm not saying his parents are
perfect right I have no idea I don't
know them they could be involved in this
whole thing I don't know I truly I'm not
accusing them I I literally do not know
but the point is is that like all the
red flags point at one guy and
everyone's like ignoring that it's all
points at John caroni and at this point
you know I'm not sure whether it matters
if you guys believe me or not because I
think in the end this man has proven
that he will self-sabotage himself
regardless of what what I do or say uh
but I just want to expose this stuff
before it all goes to zero you know
because sure he leaked the million
dollar house he leaked the wiener dog
nft he leaked the five million he leaked
his parents street address he will
eventually leak it but the question is
are you guys gonna wake up before or
after this whole thing goes to zero
right and I know some of you are gonna
say oh look the people who are still
invested they're never gonna listen at
this point but um I do think you're
right that most won't listen but there
are people on the margins that you can
still help and those are the people that
I'm talking to those are the people I'm
trying to reach right now so
um if you've been on the fence about
this stuff and you've never seen the
whole picture of John caroni the CEO of
safe moon now you have for those of you
who are just here for the entertainment
I hope you enjoy I love doing these deep
Dives and safe moon has been one of our
longest running investigations uh one of
the most painful ones too honestly
because so frustrating trying to
convince people to stop uh despite all
the evidence but either way I can't help
but do it I just love these deep Dives
and it's thanks to you that I get to do
them so anyways pump the stock that's
basically it and I will see you in the
next one